[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 78
sport l'émission consacrée à l'actualité
sportive dans le département tout de
suite le sommaire de votre magazine
rugby une rencontre entre les sapeurs
pompiers et la fédération sportive de la
police nationale s'est déroulé ce samedi
après-midi au stade de plaisir au
programme des matchs féminins et
masculins pour soutenir une association
plus de détails dans cette édition hand
bal le 25 mars prochain le vélodrome
national de 50 ans Nivine va accueillir
un match de première division féminine
entre les deux collideurs du championnat
Brest et Ici Paris plus de plus de 5000
personnes sont attendues pour participer
à l'événement nous y reviendrons dans ce
magazine et puis en fin d'émission coup
de projecteur sur le raid étudiant
saclclé Night and Day un rendez-vous
entre la vallée de Chevreuse et
rambouillé qui va regrouper plus de 400
personnes ce vendredi et ce samedi mais
avant de développer ces tites coup de
projecteur sur les principaux résultats
à du weekend dans le
[Musique]
département on commence par du basket et
la très- belle victoire de l'équipe
senior féminine du chîn Versailles lors
de la 15e journée de National 2 les
filles de vin Bardic se sont fait peur
mais ont réussi à l'emportter face à ce
mur 68 à 67 après avoir mené de près de
15 points à 3 minutes de la fin au
classement le LCV 78 qui je vous le
rappelle est promu cette saison dans
cette division est 2e avec 26 points et
un bilan de 11 victoires pour quatre
défaites on écoute le président du club
Philippe femme sur les objectifs de la
saison il y a 5 si équipes qui sont je
dirais dans un mouchoir de poche ce qui
fait aussi l'intérêt de cette poule
c'est que les matchs sont tous
intéressants en tout cas pour la la
partie haute du tableau et et l'objectif
c'estah de faire le point d'ici 4 C
matchs et de savoir si effectivement on
a pour objectif de d'aller en playoff
mais aujourd'hui l'objectif c'est de se
maintenir bon ça semble quand même bien
parti et puis surtout de terminer la la
saison en continuant se faire plaisir il
y avait également du football ce weekend
avec la 16e journée du championnat de
Division Honneur de Promotion Honneur
pardon l'équipe l'Étoile Sportive de
trappe n'a pu faire mieux que match nuls
sur le terrain de courbeevie le score un
but partout un résultat qui permet aux
joueurs d'Arnaud mbis de rester à la 6e
place du classement de la poule C avec
un bilan de 6 victoires 5 nul et deux
défaites depuis le début de la saison on
continue par du rugby pas de matchs de
championnat à ce weekend dans les
ivlines à cause des vacances mais une
affiche de gala une rencontre entre les
sapeurs pom pied la fédération sportive
de la police nationale s'est déroulée ce
samedi après-midi au stade de plaisir
les recettes de cette rencontre ont été
reversées au profit des orphelins de la
police nationale et des pompiers au
programme des matchs de rugby féminin et
masculin on écoute le DTN de la police
Francis
Castan donc des joueurs issus de de
toute la France et de différents niveaux
puisque côté policier notamment nous
avons des joueurs de fédéral 1 jusqu'à
fédéral 3 chez les féminines police il y
a un peu moins on a un effectif de 12
personnes euh par contre l'effectif des
pompiers féminines est très beaucoup
plus nombreux puis qu'il y a le double
donc il y a plus de 20 24 25 personnes
et après chez les chez les garçons que
ce soit pompiers ou policiers on est ces
deux groupes de 25 quoi au total plus de
600 € ont été récolté grâce à ce match
sur le terrain ce sont les policiers qui
ont remporté la partie 18 à 7 contre les
pompiers on va à présent parler de hand
ball le vélodrome national de 50 ans
enine va accueillir cette discipline le
25 mars prochain Ici Paris club de der
va délocaliser pour la première fois de
son histoire un match à domicile dans
l'enceinte yvelinoise pour affronter à
Brest objectif battre le record
d'affluence pour un match de première
division qui est actuellement de 5000
spectateurs Mathilde Domini pour les
images ce sera une grande première au
Vélodrome national de 50 ans en Evelin
un match de D1 Féminine de Handball va
être organisé le samedi 25 mars dans la
structure avec au programme une
rencontre de haut niveau entre les clubs
d'Ici Paris et de Brest là on est ravi
d'accueillir du
on espère après pouvoirire du basket du
volet et voilà c'est l'idée c'est
vraiment d'inscrire cette salle qui a
une salle de 6500
personnes en capacité maximale en fait
de pouvoir l'optimiser et de l'utiliser
comme une une vraie salle de sport et
spectacle j'ai encore un peu de mal à me
projeter parce que c'est un peu grand et
c'est un peu lointain par rapport aux
places des spectateurs donc je sais pas
c'est c'est excitant et en même temps ça
fait un peu peur la rencontre sera avant
tout un choc du championnat entre les
deux colliders de la division des stars
duant de ball féminin seront sur la
feuille de match parmi les joueus on
retrouvera la demi-centre stetin oftedal
médaill de bronze au dernier JO avec la
Norvège et championne du monde 2015 ça
va être très très cool c'est aussi un
match très important pour pour nous moi
j'aime bien jouer des matchs comme ça
aussi avec la pression avec beaucoup de
monde c'est c'est ça qu'on ouais qu'on
aime du monde il devrait y en avoir
l'obj annoncé ce mardi 7 février en
conférence de presse et de battre le
record de 5127 places vendues pour un
match de D1 féminine pour atteindre ce
chiffre les premiers tickets seront
accessibles à 5 €. bah déjà j'espère que
le record sera atteint en tant que
joueuse bah c'est une énorme c'est un
énorme événement donc hâte d'y être et
en même temps on a un peu d'appréhension
parce que on sait qu'on sera vu par
beaucoup de personnes et on sait qu'il
faudra bah justement faire une belle
prestation en attendant ce match de gala
Les joueus d'Ici Paris se sont déjà
familiarisés avec l'enceinte sportive en
s'essayant au traditionnel baptême de
piste le handball et le vélodrome une
histoire qui roule
déjà le vélodrome national de 50 ans
nevine va donc accueillir ce match de
prestige dans un peu plus d'un mois pour
prendre la température du du club d'Ici
Paris nous avons rencontré le président
Jean-Marie cffre à l'issue de la
conférence de presse sur ce
match alors je suis avec Jean-Marie
cffre le président d'Ici Paris alors
nous venons juste de sortir de la
conférence de presse qui a annoncé le
gros match entre Ici Paris et Brest
alors Jean-Marie est-ce que vous êtes
impatient de jouer ce gros match au
Vélodrome national de C liing qui se
trouve juste derrière nous oui impatient
impatient parce que pour nous et pour le
Vélodrome c'est une première avec un
gros challenge de remplissage et puis de
mettre une salle de handbal dans ce dans
ce vélodrome donc oui très impatient et
hâte d'y être d'autant que ce match
contre Brest va être relativement
déterminant pour la suite du championnat
détermin vous êtes premier execo est-ce
que le championnat se déroulera
finalement ici la finale du championnat
se déroulera ici alors non parce que
nous sommes en formule de play-off
championnat saison régulière plus
play-off donc en revanche le résultat de
la saison régulière a de fortes Chan de
se dérouler ici oui et comment se sont
passés les tractations pour organiser ce
ce match est-ce que c'est un travail de
longue haleine oui ça fait longtemps que
Patrick Chea président du comité de du
territoire de
debal nous demande de venir jouer un
match sur son territoire et et et on a
rencontré les gens du Vélodrome on a
rencontré Patrick cheab les élus et
cetera et et et on s'est tous mis
d'accord pour pour venir faire cet
événement vous étiez enthousiaste au
début rétissent peut-être de jouer dans
une si grande salle euh pas réticent du
tout inquiet inquiet de de de mettre une
salle de handball dans une salle comme
celle-là parce que c'est une c'est une
topologie un petit peu typique euh mais
mais au fur à mesure où on avançait dans
les discussions on s'est dit on va
relever le challenge on est un club qui
se délocalise de temps en temps en
Île-de-France on aime bien aller jouer
des matchs en dehors de notre territoire
de prédilection qui qui sont etino et
puis le Stade Pierre de Coubertin dans
le 16e à Paris euh mais mais donc on
avait très envie de venir jouer dans le
dans le 78 et dans le 78 dans une salle
comme ça c'est effectivement très
excitant qu'est-ce que vous aimeriez que
les gens retiennent de de ce match de
cet événement qu'est-ce que vous aimerez
qu'il retienne euh la capacité
d'organiser un match de handball de très
haut niveau dans une enceinte comme
celle-là et je pense que si on réussit
cet objectif ça sera un Paris gagné pour
tout le monde ici la collectivité le le
Vélodrome et le club merci beaucoup
Jean-Marie si vous êtes un amateur de
box cette nouvelle devrait vous faire
plaisir le Palais des Sports d'élancour
devrait accueillir le samedi 11 mars un
grand galas organisé par le promoteur
Malamine connay le principal
organisateur des galas en France les
papiers devraient être signés dans les
prochains jours parmi les boxeurs le
public pour avoir en action l'élan
courtois Marvin petit double champion de
France qui a son actif 20 victoires dont
10 par Cho pour une seule défaite un are
cinquantinois devrait être présent Adila
mumadi ancien champion d'Europe des
poids super moyen 21 victoires et quatre
défaites depuis le début de sa carrière
des boxeurs de la team faruja pourraient
également combattre à cette occasion on
parle du trapiste Galus colon la
décision devrait être officielle d'ici à
la fin de la semaine un mot de voile à
présent et plus précisément du vent des
globes la compétition va normalement
s'achever cette nuit pour ériic Bellon
le versaillais que vous avez pu suivre
sur notre antenne pendant toute son
aventure n'est plus qu'à quelques m000es
nautiques de l'arrivée il devrait
rejoindre les sables de Lon ce lundi 13
février dans la soirée pourtant la fin
du parcours a été très compliqué pour
l'ivinois le navigateur a eu un problème
ce weekend avec sa grand voile et à cela
s'est ajouté des problèmes de moteur et
des vents de face très puissants on
regarde cette
séquence on attaque la la
dépression euh
à bord on lâche rien on lâche rien après
les problèmes électriques problème de
Dessal j'avais plus d'eau
potable mais maintenant j'en ai donc je
peux boire j'ai changé de D et ça
fonctionne j'ai travaillé toute la
journée
làdessus comme quoi on a envie d'arriver
faut vraiment qu'on arrive on passe la
seconde dans ce magazine pour parler de
sport automobile c'est officielinois
William on va disputer le championnat de
France junior organisé par la Fédération
Française de sport automobile lancé à
cette année l'objectif est de détecter
les futurs champion du karting français
et pour les meilleurs d'entre eux leur
permettre d'évoluer dans les prochaines
années vers les catégories de monoplace
le premier rendez-vous est programmé du
17 au 19 mars au Mans quatre autres
manches sont programmées sur les
circuits d'olenet sous-bois de se
fontaine de muré et de Saint-Amant Moron
d'ici fin juillet les trois premières
remporteront une dotation pour les
championnats de France 2018 on souhaite
évidemment bon courage à William
Bertrand pour cette nouvelle saison on
passe maintenant à notre rubrique
Agenda on commence cet agenda par un
rendez-vous l'École Centrale supelc
c'est organise la première édition du
sacelé à Night and Day anciennement
appelé le prologue ce vendredi et samedi
dans la vallée de Chevreuse et à
Rambouillet l'événement rassemblera plus
de 400 étudiants de la région parisienne
à montage de Pascal Joseph un raid 100 %
étudiant entre la vallée de Chevreuse et
rambouillé c'est la promesse de
l'association étudiante centrale Supelec
la structure organise cette année la
première édition du Sacé Night and Day
cette compétition proposera un trail de
nuit de 12 km ce vendredi 17 février au
départ de la gare de coursel survette C
secour par équipe de qure mixte on a des
concurrents étudiants majoritairement et
également des entreprises partenaires
donc qui courent également sur
l'événement le principe c'est que le
vendredi soir il y a un trail de nuit de
13 km donc les concurrents partent de la
gare rire de coursell surrivette et donc
débart au flambeau et ensuite voilà il y
a un tracé de 13 km qu'il doivent suivre
à la frontale le lendemain les
concurrents vont se retrouver autour du
château de rambouiller sur un parcours
modulable en VTT et à pied en parallèle
de la course des animations multisport
sont proposé dans un village sportif en
marche de la course il y a du Big Air
Bag des choses des minijeux lancés de
bûche de de l'arc trappe donc c'est en
fait c'est bal traape avec un arc donc
plein d'activités comme ça en marche de
la course c'est un événement qui se veut
vraiment à la fois accessible aux
personnes très très sportives qui
veulent vraiment faire de la performance
et aux personnes qui veulent juste
passer une bonne journée entre amis
cette année le rendez-vous affiche
complet plus de 400 étudiants se sont
inscrits pour
l'événement un autre raid de 100 %
étudiant est programmé à cette semaine
le 4L trophé sera organisé de ce jeudi à
16 février au 26 février entre la France
et le Maroc plus de 2500 jeunes vont
parcourir à cette occasion à 6000 km
parmi les participants on trouve des
élèves de l'estaka une dizaine d'équipes
se sont constitué dans l'école
d'ingénieur situé à montig Bretonneux
ils sont actuellement en train de
préparer les voitures pour le grand
départ on écoute Étienne colollet qui
fait partie de l'équipe esta 4L alors
tout le monde peut y aller si on se fait
préparer la voiture mais généralement il
fautme avoir des notion de mécanique
parce que une 4elle ça tombe souvent en
panne et non et puis on apprend enfin
moi personnellement je connaissais pas
grand-chose avant de avant de commencer
on apprend sur le tas mais on a beaucoup
de on a beaucoup de d'équipages qui nous
forment aussi c'est la fin de ce sat
sport merci avoir suivi je vous retrouve
lundi prochain pour un nouveau magazine
d'ici là passer une excellente semaine
sportive très belle soirée sur TVfil
[Musique]